all right guys
bang bang i've got ronin here i am super
excited to do this we are going to do a
complete deep dive
on psychedelics and the psychedelic
industry thank you so much for doing
this sir
my pleasure happy to have a chat for
sure let's jump right into your
background you've had a very kind of
storied
entrepreneurial career maybe just walk
us through kind of what you've done up
until this point
yeah absolutely so i i started my career
actually as a lawyer
working on bay street for those who
don't know what that is it's kind of the
canadian equivalent to wall street
working at a prestigious firm
i quickly realized that was not the life
for me i was
i was once described as being too
creative to be a lawyer and i take that
with a badge of honor so
i was actively involved in various
entrepreneurial startups all along
uh and quickly left the private practice
of law
working in various businesses as a
lawyer until i really got my chops in
entrepreneurship
that was about 2011 when i opened my
first business
which is in the gold industry it still
operates to this day actually
but it was never my lifelong ambition to
be in the gold industry so i went back
started working with startups really as
a lawyer but with a view to kind of
getting involved on a deeper level and
through those activities
i found my business partners joseph and
hernan and
and ryan um in this current business and
field trip health actually
um uh they were looking at doing
something in the canadian medical
cannabis industry this was late 2013
and and uh you know they're trying to
figure something out but they're a
little bit hesitant because of the
stigma
and just through my path and my career
being a lawyer and various other
activities i was like there's no stigma
here guys this is legal this is like the
greatest opportunity how often do you
get an opportunity where like a
multi-billion if not trillion dollar
black market
turns overnight into a legal market you
know how can you miss this and so after
cajoling them for a little while we all
kind of joined forces and
and we started uh two sister companies
one called canvas rx one called canadian
cannabis clinics
the latter groups the largest network of
cannabis specialized medical clinics in
canada
30 locations have helped well over a
hundred thousand canadians access the
legal medical cannabis system
and canvas rx we sold to a company
fledgling um cannabis company called
aurora cannabis inc recently got
licensed to produce cannabis
uh but had big ambitions and a really
amazing ceo
terry booth whose energy was just
boundless i've never met a guy who works
so hard and was so caring and thoughtful
at the same time
uh and so we joined aurora helped aurora
grow from a small csc listed company
with a 65 million dollar market cap
when we left in 2018 it was a 10 billion
new york stock exchange
listed company uh so it was a fun couple
of viewers there um
and after we left we kind of were
looking for something new to do
and that's when we learned about what
was happening in psychedelics we didn't
come from a background in cannabis or in
psychedelics being like
you know being super cannabis advocates
or being psychonauts or anything along
those lines and i think that's really
what
has enabled us to excel in both
industries as we kind of came in
objective
thoughtful professional and really
brought that level of
focus and discipline to both industries
and that's kind of helped us
to do what we do so in 2018
i started looking into all the research
we saw that peter thiel had just made an
investment in a
company called compass pathways the
magic of linkedin enabled us to chat
with the ceo
usually linkedin is a big waste of time
but in this time
instance it actually worked out well for
us you know we got connected to rick
doblin
we spoke to michael paulin who had just
published how to change your mind
and started learning and became
fascinated uh
with the science and the evidence coming
out around psychedelics and and quickly
got to the
point where like holy [ __ ] this stuff is
going to be legal way sooner than
anybody could imagine this is coming and
it's coming fast
you know what can we do we had had this
amazing experience with cannabis
kind of going in a little bit agnostic
to the therapeutic potential of cannabis
but seeing a great business opportunity
and then being truly blown away and
moved uh by the impact it had you know
almost uniformly all of the physicians
who now work at canadian cannabis
clinics refer to cannabis as the most
effective medicine they've ever
prescribed to their patients in terms of
quality of life
and so you know we had a we had a great
exit when we sold that business and and
so we kind of looked at psychedelics as
being a really great opportunity to
create a new
incredible business but create massive
impact you know this is kind of the
opportunity
um of the scale of you know elon musk
and spacex and what he's trying to do or
jeff bezos and you know
this is massive scale massive impact
opportunity when you look at the
evidence around psychedelics and
so we kind of dug in learned as much as
we could
spent about a year trying to figure out
how to build a business in psychedelics
because what are you going to do all of
these are still scheduled by and large
uh crafted our our business plan and
launched field trip about a year and a
half ago and that's kind of the path
here
it's awesome um let's start at a very
high level
what is a psychedelic right everyone
hears that they kind of it used to be
very very fringe now it's less fringe in
terms of when people are talking about
it
but just from your understanding after
having done all that research
what is a psychedelic yeah you know and
there's still ongoing debate as to what
is a psychedelic it's it's not a defined
answer
i will tell you how we think about it we
think about a psychedelic
as anything that slows the ego or tunes
down the ego slows the default mode
network in the brain which is kind of
the parts of the brain that operate as
the operating system that keep you going
even when you're not thinking about
things
anything that tunes those down slows
those down and
opens you up to change uh is what we
consider
a psychedelic and so that can be
psychedelic drugs um
like lsd or psilocybin or
it could be meditation or breath work if
you haven't tried breath work it is a
super cool experience how you could
induce an almost trip like state just
just through different breathing
techniques
so to us any of those are psychedelics
and because they enable the capacity
for change but for other people if you
want to get more focused on the
chemistry
uh typically psychedelics refer to
molecules
that engage the 5-ht2a serotonin
receptor in the brain
so that's lsd that's psilocybin that's
dmt
that's five meodmt uh which are known
psychedelics it's peyote
um just about anything you can sort of
think of when you think about the
counterculture and hippie movements
those are
are classically uh psychedelics mdma
is lumped into that category as well
mdma is not conventionally a psychedelic
in that respect but
it offers very similar experiences and
it really does the same thing of
slowing the default mode network tuning
down the ego and enabling
change so that gets put in the category
as well but it is a pretty fluid
definition
absolutely and so one of the things
that's really interesting to me
is uh there's kind of two use cases i
think that now are presenting themselves
there's like this medicinal type use
case and then there's more of a
recreational or wellness type use case
it mirrors i know you've talked about it
before a lot of what happened
uh so far in the cannabis industry maybe
talk about
that framework and how you think about
each one of those use cases developing
whether it's from a legal structure
standpoint
or from an actual just development of
the industry
sure so when we got excited about
psychedelics certainly
um you know the the evidence around the
treatment of depression and ptsd and
anxiety and all of these
uh clinically diagnosed mental health
conditions was incredibly exciting you
know that's incredible
impact but it's kind of focused on and
it's a function of the entire
modern western allopathic medicine
approach
uh which is you focus on what's wrong
and try and sort of come back to
baseline right
so people who are sick you give them
medicine and they come back to baseline
to be
quote unquote normal but you know the
five guys behind field trip all of us
kind of have a little bit of we're not
super bio hackers but we're always
focused on
optimization and increasing our
creativity and empathy and awareness and
i know i've spent 15 years working with
meditation and metaphysics
and self-exploration independent of
psychedelics
really just trying to have a better life
to be happier to be a better parent
be a better partner all of these things
these are just part of personal growth
and so that was the part of the industry
that probably excited us
more just personally and inevitably when
you start a business usually you build a
business to satisfy your own
desires and and so what we see happening
what happened in the cannabis industry
as many people know is that
most programs started off as a medical
program which means you needed to go to
a doctor
get a diagnosis you know whether it's
back pain or
migraines or you had hiv aids which is
where a lot of the movements started and
you wanted something to help manage the
symptoms around that but you needed a
doctor you needed a diagnosis and you
needed a prescription and then you can
access medical cannabis
and then eventually that involved to
adult use cannabis where people can just
buy cannabis like they
they can buy alcohol and and that's fine
and i think you know
philosophically the war on drugs never
made a whole lot of sense uh so it it
kind of
is is totally rational and coherent that
that happened there
in psychedelics what we see happening is
a little bit different you know when we
looked at the
the evidence and where things were going
we thought it was certainly wonderful
that um
there was a path through fda approval in
clinical trials
to create new medicines using psilocybin
and mdma to treat depression to treat
anxiety to treat ptsd
certainly but we always felt that that
would be
um a little bit a little bit less than
ideal outcome right because
psychedelics can help just about
everybody you know there's certain kind
of
contraindications where people shouldn't
be taking psychedelics but for most
people
psychedelic experiences can be very
illuminating they can help you process
traumas they can help you be more well
self-sustaining
creative empathetic all of these
wonderful things
um and uh so what we saw emerging and
what has now happened with the passage
of measure 109 in oregon
is that two systems are now clearly in
place one is going to be purely medical
and these drugs are going through fda
trials their phase three programs
and once they get approved they're going
to be prescribable by doctors for the
treatment of mental health conditions
and that's great for people who are
suffering with these conditions but for
anyone else who's not sick but could
potentially benefit they get excluded
from that program
and so what we saw happen in oregon and
what we expect to see on a
state-by-state
basis much like we saw with cannabis is
programs that are really
accessible to all people you don't have
to be sick you don't have to have a
diagnosis of a mental health condition
um to access it but what will diff
differentiate it a bit from cannabis is
that it will be more controlled it's not
going to be that you go to a dispensary
and buy mushrooms or or whatever and
take them home
you'll have to go to a licensed
facilitator or clinician you won't have
to be sick you don't have to be
depressed but you'll have to go to a
controlled environment
and it'll be accessible to anybody who
wants to use it and the great thing
about that program is there's greater
access
people who can benefit from psychedelics
without being sick will have access
but the benefit of being in within the
medical program
if you want to talk about it in terms of
benefits is that there'll be insurance
coverage right these will be fda
approved drugs they'll have indications
and if you fit that indication and you
get a prescription and you want to seek
treatment there'll be a lot more robust
insurance coverage so it won't be as
expensive but we think both of those are
going to emerge
and that's great because the sick will
have better access to programs
the people with mental health will have
better access and lower cost access to
programs but
the people who don't need it but want it
will be able to access it as well
talk to me a little bit about the
science and kind of how far
along the industry is so you know in
preparation for this i read a whole
bunch of different things
uh and it seems like there are now many
many studies that are starting to show
the efficacy
uh whether it is for ptsd whether it is
for other mental
trauma um it just seems like now we're
we're
getting close if not already to this
point where like the evidence is
overwhelmingly positive that like
this works uh specifically around the
medicinal side
how do you guys view that scientific
data and some of the studies that have
already been done
i mean i think it's essential and i
think the reason that the psychedelic
renaissance is happening
so rapidly especially as you compare it
to cannabis is because that evidence is
so robust and so persuasive you know you
look at
this movement really started about 20
years ago when ketamine
which is a legal and prescribable drug
in most countries around the world as an
anesthetic
was shown to have very positive effects
on the treatment of depression so much
so that dr
tom insell he used to be the director of
the national institute of mental health
that
said it was the most important
breakthrough in the treatment of
depression in 50 years or something
along those lines and that sort of
kicked off this
interest in psychoactive drugs
for the treatment of mental health and
then probably 10-15 years ago you had
some very
enterprising researchers from johns
hopkins and imperial college in in
london
uh who started looking at psilocybin
again for the treatment of mental health
conditions
now what's really interesting is you
know you i don't know how old you are
but we probably had very similar high
school experiences where we were taught
about like how
terrible drugs are this you're bringing
on drugs and all that kind of stuff
but the history of of most psychedelics
actually starts in either
cultural spiritual uses or in the modern
western context in research you know
this was harvard university in the
late 50s and early 60s advancing the
research on lsd for mental health
conditions which showed profound
profoundly positive results but the lsd
kind of left the lab and and went into
the mainstream the counterculture and
you had the whole political backlash so
the researchers who picked it up in the
last 15 years or so were really working
off a base of evidence and that evidence
shows
incredible efficacy you know when you
look at psilocybin
for the treatment of depression you know
there's a study that came out uh from
nyu
a couple months ago that showed that a
single psilocybin assisted therapy
session and it's important to note that
when we talk about psychedelic therapies
it's really the interplay of the drug
with the therapy it's not just given the
drug like we
think of antidepressants or antibiotics
or anything along those lines it's
really the interplay but
there's a study of nyu that showed a
single psilocybin assisted therapy
session could provide
antidepressant effects for up to five
years one session
five years you know when you compare
that to antidepressants which you have
to take every day this is like
it's almost crazy uh that we would be
considering
using antidepressants going forward or
you look at the studies with mdma
and an organization a non-profit called
maps which is the
multi-disciplinary association for
psychedelic studies which has been doing
this for 30 years
um you know god god bless rick for his
discipline and
and drive to see this through after all
that time you know in their phase two
clinical study fda approved clinical
study
uh they showed that close to 70 percent
of people with chronic severe ptsd
were no longer categorized as having
ptsd anymore you know you're talking
about an effective
cure of ptsd and some of the most
rigorous and robust clinical trials you
can you can imagine
uh and it it's across the spectrum you
know
with anxiety you see similar results
we'll be hosting a trial looking at mdma
for the treatment of anorexia at some
point so any mental health conditions
and and the amazing thing is that these
molecules are
incredibly safe by and large you know
they're non-addictive may even be
anti-addictive when you talk about
psilocybin or lsd
uh the results speak for themselves and
they also have these
pro-social side effects right you know
people not only report that
they have significantly improved
depression or anxiety they also report
that
you know they have increased creativity
increased empathy more openness to other
people's viewpoints which is something
that seems sorely lacking
around the world these days um as well
as like greater connection to nature and
the planet so not only are they being
cured they're actually their lives are
being improved over and above
treatment of their conditions so the
research isn't is quite profound
the safety profile these molecules is
pretty well established
um and it's just growing you know
there's a few
major studies that have been given
breakthrough therapy status by the fda
which means not only has the fda decided
that
you know these show incredible promise
but they meet an urgent need
you know it really is quite the platform
that we're working from from with a lot
of
research and support behind it yeah one
of the things that's really interesting
to me
is uh you shared the kind of this chart
around the harmfulness of various drugs
and
things like mdma lsd you know other
types of psychedelics or some of the
least harmful drugs you can put in your
body
right if you compare that you know to
alcohol or or whatever it is
and so it almost begs the question of
like whether it's
through medicinal or recreational
purposes
what's the downside of this right so
it's kind of
was it just a side effect of the war on
drugs and this got lumped in with
everything and therefore
uh kind of it took a detour if you will
for a couple of decades uh
and was deemed you know illegal and bad
because the government said so uh or are
there other things that
um you guys kind of look at and say look
we know that there are specific side
effects that could be negative
but the positives outweigh those
negatives
yeah i mean with any drugs there's
always gonna with anything you know too
much of a good thing can be a bad thing
and that's certainly true with all drugs
and as well as psychedelics but
i think you hit on the key point which
is the benefits
particularly with psychedelics far
outweigh the downsides you know the the
biggest
risks around psychedelics by and large
you know most are
anti-addictive or non-addictive so
you're not going to get hooked on them
like you could with
other drugs like cocaine or heroin if
we're talking about illicit drugs
there's with psilocybin and lsd at least
there's no ld50
which means you really can't overdose
that's the point of death you know there
was a
study it was an end of one but a woman
took something like 10 000
micrograms of lsd which is like 40 times
a significant dose of lsd and she was
sick for a couple of days
um but it seemed to cure her bipolar
disorder
and she was fine afterwards so you know
that it's it's you're not gonna die on
these
um by and large uh so you know they're
relatively safe in that regard the
biggest
risk is there's two risks around
psychedelics the biggest risk
is people having bad trips you know we
probably heard
all of the urban legends of someone
having a trip and launching themselves
off a building and the truth is
that has happened but not with the
frequency uh
by which you know we may have learned in
high school
um but bad trips you know the current
belief is that there's no such thing as
a
bad trip there are hard trips and there
are easy trips a hard trip can still be
incredibly therapeutic when
supported by the right therapy but if it
doesn't have the right container
around it it can turn into a bad trip
and a bad trip much like a nightmare can
create its own
instance of ptsd so there are potentials
for negatives but
generally the risk is relatively low
it's not zero
um but the risk is relatively low and
especially with the right supporting
context
it's much lower and that's about it
there's also reports
of a condition where people have taken a
psychedelic
and like the experience takes a long
time to go away i forget exactly what
the
acronym is but it's essentially a
persistent trip that lasts for a long
time
and that does happen in rare instances
as well but it does seem to subside
after some period of time but that can
also be uh probably very unpleasant for
those people who experience it
um outside of that though the risks are
fairly minimal
and and the upsides are obviously quite
significant
absolutely i'm assuming that you've
taken the psychedelics and kind of
experienced this for yourself
and so can you maybe describe to people
what the actual experience is right i
think people hear the psychedelic
um you know they read about it but if
you've never actually
taken them is it something where
you can attribute it to like being drunk
is it more like
you know being high on marijuana is it
like cocaine is it something completely
different like
how would you describe the actual
experience
um it really depends i mean i haven't
tried all psychedelics so i can't speak
from personal experience on
all of them but um you know
it if i was going to speak to psilocybin
which is where my personal experience is
and i talk about it quite extensively
actually on our podcast which is called
field tripping
um the the experience is kind of like
it's a little bit like cannabis you know
you kind of feel
the voices in your head all of the
thoughts kind of slow down
a little bit and so you become more
aware of what's going on around you
depending on the drug that can also come
through in very colorful expressions you
know
they've taken people who have who are on
psilocybin and put them in an
fmri machine to see what's happening in
the brain and what they've found is that
when you're on a psychedelic
parts of your brain that typically don't
talk to each other you're talking to
each other quite frequently so that's
why people
experience a much more robust sense
of the world right they can feel music
more they can taste music more or
art is more colorful and there's
actually a neurological reason for it is
that the parts of your brain are talking
to each other more so your experience is
actually more
integrated um and so on psilocybin you
know you kind of feel like a little bit
of spaciness but you're still coherent
you're still very conscious you're not
reckless like you're drunk you know your
judgment is still fairly well intact but
if you close your eyes you will
typically have an incredible
visual experience you know a lot of the
tropes about the 1960s and lsd a lot of
those
kind of experiences and those color
experiences do happen when you take
psilocybin
if you take it and go inward you know
you'll often experience
past moments in your life you'll be able
to see them with a degree of objectivity
you've never seen them with before
you'll have creative ideas you know a
lot of these things are
pretty comparable to cannabis or
drinking in some respects but
they land more they they're you're easy
it's easier to hold on to them more they
don't just
dissipate they're much more meaningful
to you
that's probably how i describe the
experience i've never taken ketamine
personally but a lot of people talk
about ketamine
um and have an experience whereby
you know they just feel like you know
they're a little bit in outer space or
underwater and can see the world in just
a much different way you know it's still
very much themselves it's just kind of
like
being in a little bit of outer space and
or an out of body experience as well
they can still be colorful they can
still be very vibrant but it's a little
bit more objective
um that's that's how i would describe it
you know i think everyone's
experiences are personal and then they
can definitely go dark and
um you know as a nod to michael paulin
in his book how to change your mind he
goes into depth about what his trip
experiences were like uh when he did lsd
and psilocybin and he's probably much
more eloquent and poetic about it than i
am so
if anyone wants to you know get a deeper
sense that'd be a good place to look
yeah and uh i apologize in advance i'm
probably going to ask a bunch of really
naive elementary questions so
stick with me the experience you just
described
is uh very positive right almost like
this
thing where you're ingesting something
that unblocks a lot of the blockage in
your brain and so you can see that
either from a
kind of internal uh you know review
right
and it would make sense as to uh things
like ptsd um
you know therapies and things like that
that would make a ton of sense because
you can actually get somebody to kind of
go through that experience talk through
it and things like that but also there's
this external
component uh you just see the world
differently we can kind of sum it up
like that
um that is in stark contrast to
uh maybe uh something like an ayahuasca
right where people basically describe
uh vomiting and diarrhea and kind of a
much more like cleansing type activity
uh
does the psychedelic community consider
things like ayahuasca to be part of it
is it kind of there's a gray area and it
just depends where you draw the line
like
how do you think about something that i
think people look at as much more
like cleansing the body versus uh almost
like this like mental trip that you just
described
yeah no ayahuasca is certainly part of
the psychedelic experience you know a
lot of people
have ayahuasca experiences ayahuasca the
active
drug in iowa ayahuasca is dmt which is
actually something that our body
naturally synthesizes just in very small
proportions but it's thought
actually that the experience that people
have when they die you know you've heard
of like the white light and seeing all
of your family
it's thought that that may be a big
release of dmt in your body
so um so the ayahuasca experienced
you know there's a lot of physical
purging a lot of people associate that
physical purging
as emotional purging as well you know
they're you're getting rid of the demons
you're getting rid of the trauma
but it's not unique to ayahuasca it's
much
more physical and visceral but you know
one time when i i had an experience with
psilocybin
i felt my body moving i felt like my i
was
wretching like i was throwing up but i
wasn't throwing up i didn't feel like i
was throwing up but my body was doing
that activity
and it very much felt the same way so it
depends on the depth of the experience
but
um that's not unique to ayahuasca
the intensity of the fact that you
actually throw up is is you know
typically unique to ayahuasca but not
exclusively
but that processing it really does feel
like um
depending on the experience you know
your body is
purging held emotions and if you look at
you know some of the theories of what
drives depression and anxiety
a lot of it is repressed emotion you
know we don't we're as a society we're
terrible
at feeling our emotions and expressing
our emotions and processing our emotions
and that
takes energy that takes effort and and
we tend to bury them into our
subconscious
and so one of the thoughts is with with
psychedelics
is that it unpacks that and i've
certainly had that feeling as well that
like when i was on psilocybin
you know i felt like a part of my brain
that was closed off and not accessible
you know very feminine kind of energy
came out
and started helping me like work through
all of these things that i've held on to
for my entire life and so i didn't throw
up but my body actually made the motions
like i was going to throw up
and and just as as a quick side note
just uh if people are interested about
why it's believed that psychedelics can
be so therapeutic and so effective it's
really
thought that there's three kind of
interactions that are happening
uh when you ingest a psychedelic one is
there's almost an immediate
antidepressant effect whether it's
ketamine or psilocybin or mdma as soon
as it hits you most people report a lift
in mood
and so it kind of takes you if you're in
a depression or in a funk it will pull
you out of that immediately
secondly um it helps you see
old experiences and old traumas more
objectively so you can start to process
the emotions and and move them through
your body as well um so you start to
process the trauma it's very similar
like to talk therapy
but on a hyper expedited basis right
like it just gets right down to the
business instead of taking years
you know your brain is just like forcing
you to confront those issues and start
processing them
and the third way that psychedelic
therapy seems to have such incredible
impact
is that there's a period of neural
plasticity that happens after you take a
psychedelic michael paul then referred
to it as like if you imagine
cross-country ski tracks
a fresh dump of snow kind of landing on
top of it so
you have a new opportunity to create new
paths quite literally in your brain
um and so when you pair that with
psychotherapy when you have a
therapist there with you you know using
different techniques
you're actually much more able to
adopt those habits those changes into
your lifestyle into your brain
and so you have this lasting kind of
actual change it's kind of like
you know when you take plato and warm it
up with your hands it becomes much more
malleable that's literally what's
happening with your brain
so you can reshape a lot of things in a
positive way and and so
that's kind of what's believed to be
happening when you have a psychedelic
experience and why these
effects are so profound and so lasting
yeah
you mentioned uh kind of at the point of
death there's this belief that a ton of
dmt gets released um one of the
questions that
uh somebody sent me on twitter that i
know nothing about and found fascinating
was this idea of
basically at the point of death to
administer
a psychedelic to somebody to almost make
it a less painful
i guess in some weird way a more
enjoyable experience
is that something that is more on like
the
fringe and kind of a one-off idea or is
that something that is being taken
seriously by the scientific community
and kind of the psychedelic community
i can't speak for everybody it's not
something that i've heard
a lot of um personally there's a lot of
interest in using psychedelics as part
of palliative care
because some of the more interesting
studies like the one i mentioned from
nyu
it was actually giving psilocybin
assistive therapy
to people with terminal cancer who were
facing end of life distress
and those people reported a significant
improvement in
their anxiety around dying because one
of the other experiences that people
often have is like a sense of
connectedness
uh you know i've been reading the
immortality key which is a book that
kind of looks to
um you know psychedelic use in ancient
greece and how that actually translated
into early christianity and all that
kind of stuff but one of the things it
talks about was that in ancient greece
uh there was a ritual called the the
mysteries of elusis and all of the great
ancient greek philosophers
had this and almost uniformly everybody
who went through the mysteries
reported that they no longer feared
death because they actually saw
that life like this was literally just a
shell your body is just a shell but your
life continues well afterwards
and the people report that experience to
this day so that's where a lot of the
interest is
um specifically to dmt or
other psychedelics right at the kind of
moment of death i haven't heard of that
but erwin pearlman who's the gentleman
i've been working with for the last 15
years and kind of my meditation and
metaphysical practice metaphysics
practice
kind of talks about most people when
they die actually look very
relieved and pleased right like it is
actually
the moment up to it is actually
terrifying but the actual moment of it
is actually quite relieving at least
that
that's what he talks about and that may
be in part triggered by the dmt
um but beyond that i don't know
specifically any research that's
happening on it
yeah it's it's just fascinating to kind
of think through
um you know there's the medical
uh in the legacy sense that you can
treat terminal cancer you know things
like that but also then there's this
mental component to it if you can almost
make
the experience uh less acute for
somebody
you know there's a lot of benefit to
that one of the other questions that i
got
um but this probably the most popular
one was all around micro dosing
so maybe just start with like what is
micro dosing uh and then i think
from the questions i was surprised at
how many people
uh at least claim that they micro dose
on a daily basis and so
what exactly is that and kind of why
would people be doing it on a more
frequent basis
yeah so when we talk about the research
around psychedelics it's typically using
macro or transformational level doses so
if you were to equate it to mushrooms
it'd be like five grams of mushrooms
which is a significant dose of magic
mushrooms
micro dosing would be the equivalent of
taking
100 milligrams or 200 milligrams and
it's supposed to be subperceptual so you
don't
really notice it but you're really
treating the psychedelic much more like
an antidepressant take it on a daily
basis or a frequent basis to
improve mood um and and uh
creativity and um
the challenge with microdosing is that
there's a lot of anecdotal evidence of
its effectiveness but there's really
no substantive research that's been done
on it so it's really hard to say
whether it's effective or not at least
on a scientific basis
from what i've heard there are some
studies that have been going on recently
that haven't been published but they
suggest that
micro dosing is no more effective than
placebo
so suggesting that micro dosing is not
effective
but it's really unknown right now but
the whole idea is taking small doses
on a frequent basis um to enhance
creativity and so what you hear people
in silicon valley doing and all that
kind of stuff and a lot of people swear
by it and
and that's great and if it's working for
them that's fantastic one of the risks
and we didn't really touch upon this
when we talk about the risks of
psychedelics because
it's typically only a risk if there's
you know very frequent
high use of psychedelics but um
drugs like psilocybin they're
promiscuous you know they primarily
engage the 5 hd 2a serotonin receptor
which means
that's the psychedelic receptor that
causes the psychedelic experience or at
least it's believed so
but they can also engage or agonize the
5-hd
2b receptor in the brain which has been
associated
if it is agonized too much or too
frequently with um
potential cardiac issues heart valve
fibrosis
and issues like that and so that's one
of the concerns around micro dosing is
that if you're taking frequently you
may be wandering into what's called the
five hd 2b liability
unknown um you know and a lot of people
like paul stamets have been
micro dosing for years and years and
seem to be okay so
but it is one of the things you want to
be conscious with if you are engaging in
a micro dosing practice is
it's it's probably it's it's probably
got a higher risk
profile uh than doing the very
occasional
high dose experience just given the
frequency of use and that potential risk
but
i don't know how significant that risk
is it's just something to keep in mind
yeah what's interesting about this is
micro dosing seems similar to somebody
who
takes adderall every day the difference
being that the adderall almost
speeds up the thought process speeds up
the focus and
makes somebody more of a kind of i call
it like a rigid machine right like just
you can just knock out work for hours
and hours and hours
versus this which is a much more
frequent uh
you know kind of uh consumption of it
but it has the opposite effect almost
right it's like a more creative
slowing down uh more laid-back type
approach and so
um you know if that framework is
accurate uh it's almost like
well adderall is legal through a doctor
and kind of has a specific effect it
would make sense i guess
that um kind of the opposite intended
uh state could be achieved uh on a daily
basis but sounds like
that may not actually even be necessary
right you could almost just do it
periodically um and and have some
lasting effects there as well it sounds
like
yeah absolutely you know um you know
your brain
the experience of psychedelics when done
properly with therapy is is that you you
actually have change
you have neurological change you have
emotional change and it's lasting and
it's
substantiated um uh but you know
comparing
dosing to taking adderall daily you know
i don't know enough about adderall where
they speak about the experience but
um but you know it can be used in that
way but probably with different intent
and different effect and you know
truthfully you know there's something
about that that appeals to me logically
you know i've been trying i have a
stepson who's
19 years old and you know he went to
university and
he's asking what he should study and i
said the most important two features the
two most important skills in the future
are going to be the ability to
concentrate
because in our digital phone era the
concentration and like attention levels
have dropped so much
and the second thing is creativity you
know math and science and engineering
all of that's going to be done by
computers you know anything that's
logical
can be done by computers way better than
it can be done by us
creativity where you have to like jump
the gap where there's no
logical answer and you have to fill in
the gap through creativity
that's going to be the most important
skill set in the world and so to the
extent that psychedelics either
microdosing or
you know transformational doses of it
are going to facilitate that you know i
see
them having a significant impact beyond
just
mental health treatments in the future
as well absolutely no
it makes makes complete sense talk to me
a little bit about
the strategy for uh field trip is
this like set and setting um type
approach and so
for uh you know most people when they
think of psychedelics they're thinking
about the actual thing that is being
consumed
and then the impact that has on your
mental
or emotional state um this idea that you
guys have around like well
a big part of the experience is driven
by the environment in which you are in
and what can kind of be done there just
walk us through like what is the
strategy
and kind of why is that so important
yeah so when we started with field trip
and we started doing the research and we
spoke to everybody the consistent theme
we heard
is there's going to be no money in the
drugs there's only going to be
money and a business to be made in the
delivery of psychedelic therapies
and that kind of resonated with us
because we just spent a couple of years
building a whole clinical infrastructure
cannabis or like okay well we're
extremely well positioned to do this for
for psychedelics um and what we realized
is that
uh psychedelics don't fit into
conventional medicine you know you can't
go to your family doctor and expect him
or her to administer
psilocybin and have you hang out at
their office for six or eight hours
while you go through a trip right they
don't have the space they don't have the
staffing and they're not interested in
doing it so
there was there is going to be a real
need for this new um
clinical infrastructure so that's what
we started with um
but then we realized that because so
much and there's
an incredible amount of evidence around
this so much of the therapeutic
experience
comes down to the set and setting which
refers to the mindset of the person so
what preparation
they bring into the psychedelic
experience and what their intentions you
know what do i want to get out of this
some people may come in and just be like
you know i spoke with alex icon again
one of the guys who founded the
five-minute journal and he said i went
in and just said universe show me what i
need to see
other people will go in and be like i
need to get over
the breakup with my boyfriend or
something along those lines so
the the mindset is the set and set and
setting
and the setting is is actually the space
the physical space there's evidence to
show that
if you're in a warm safe naturally
natural or naturally inspired
environment typically you're going to
have
better therapeutic outcomes as opposed
to being in a hospital setting with
fluorescent lights and white walls and
so as we were building a field trip
knowing that you needed this clinical
infrastructure you needed new space you
needed new operations you needed new
protocols to actually make this scalable
we also focused very heavily on the
setting as well so if you go into any of
our clinics we are currently operating
in new york toronto chicago and la with
plans for many more
uh you'll notice that these do not feel
like doctors offices they feel
much more and i don't like the term i
don't know why but it feels very
spa-like i think i don't like the term
piece that kind of diminishes the impact
and the importance of what we're doing
but
um it feels that way it feels very warm
it feels very comfortable and we've
invested heavily in that and
what makes field trip really unique is
our focus on both aspects of it we're
focused on
both developing the drugs so we are in
preclinical stages and
we talk about this more with um ft-104
which is a novel synthetic psychedelic
molecule that's actually been derived
from known psychedelics
as well as we're doing advanced
cultivation research on psilocybin
producing mushrooms
um on one side of the equation but we're
focused on doing that
in parallel with developing the know-how
and understanding of what aspects of set
and setting
matter you know we know it's important
to feel like you're in a safe
warm comfortable environment but we
don't know specifically what music
matters or what lighting matters or you
know the chair or how you're sitting
or what's on the walls you know all
these things can have an impact but no
one's really got
objective data on exactly what
differences they make so
with field trip health centers that are
rolling out we're focused obviously on
delivering care using ketamine assisted
therapy right now
but also collecting the data on what
dynamics really affect the outcome so
when we come to market with
a a new product you know not only are we
going to have
best-in-class society-producing
mushrooms or best-in-class to prove drug
we're also going to be able to support
that experience because if
you're doing one without the other then
you leave a lot to chance right you know
if you've developed like a new
you know you've got approval for
psilocybin but the doctors who are
administering it are doing it in
hospital settings and people are having
terrible experiences
you got a great drug but you're not
creating the outcomes that you may have
hoped for and so we didn't want to leave
that to risk we don't think it's
the best for therapeutic outcomes and we
certainly don't think it's the best for
business model either
so we took an integrated approach with
it talk a little bit more about kind of
the set
aspect of the setting so this whole idea
of like the mindset
what do people normally do beforehand to
kind of prepare
um you talked a little bit about kind of
like what are they trying to get out of
it but
what can they do or what do they do to
kind of almost condition themselves to
be in the best
position uh to kind of have the best
experience
yeah we actually we launched an app too
called trip which is on ios and android
and that
kind of takes you very through a very
simplified process of
both the preparation as well as the
after integration work after you're done
a trip and there's cool music and
and generative music built in there but
really what you want to do is try and
tap into like your inner
emotional network what's going on you
know um
because most people don't take time to
stop and reflect why am i feeling
anxious about this or why am i angry
about that
or you know anything along those lines
so if you have a
a an intention if you have a a known
subject that you want to go into
reflecting on it and doing a little bit
of the work to unpack
the emotions or just recognize the
emotions that are around it
uh is important or you know if you're
suffering through depression
you know just taking some time to
breathe and and open yourself up to just
acknowledging
that and having compassion for yourself
being like you know this is a function
of a whole bunch of circumstances i i'm
not to blame
you know i'm maybe nervous about going
in and trying ketamine or psilocybin for
the first time so can i
process that nervousness can i breathe
through it and can i
open myself up to the experience because
within the context of set and setting
there's this uh there's this idea of
surrender which is
the more you can let go and just lean
into the experience the more therapeutic
it's going to be
whereas if you're anxious if you're
worried you know
you don't want to let go of control you
know which is a lot of people
people a lot of people don't do drugs
because quote unquote they don't want to
give up control
um and if you're going to resist the
experience you're not going to have this
therapeutic outcome so
preparation and trying to like let go of
the anxiety and lean into the experience
can also be very beneficial as well
yeah i was reading about ft-104 which is
this
uh kind of synthetic compound that you
guys are working on
maybe help people understand uh first
the
natural uh psilocybin um
kind of what the understanding there is
what the importance of
a synthetic compound and then what the
advantages
of the ft-104 compound specifically is
yeah so psilocybin is the active
ingredient in magic mushrooms
um i probably should have clarified that
earlier it's a tryptamine
um i don't know specifically what that
means in terms of chemical structure i'm
not a scientist by background
so a lot of the um a lot of the
the research and a lot of the excitement
is around psilocybin and
in part because it's a naturally
occurring substance you know there's a
lot of interest in plant-based medicine
and even though the clinical trials
happening right now we're using a
synthetic form
so a chemically synthesized form not
something that's extracted from the
actual mushroom itself
you know there's a lot of interest in it
because of its natural existence because
the fact that's been used for thousands
of years in traditional cultures and
there's
known evidence around it in terms of
safety at least anecdotally as well as
efficacy
there's a lot of excitement there so
that's really between md
mdma and psilocybin those are the two
drugs that have
really been the catalyst for the
psychedelic renaissance that's happening
right now
one of the biggest challenges with
psilocybin though as as
effective and and with such great
potential as it has is it's a long
experience you know when you take a
large dose of
psilocybin you're you're going to commit
you know
four six eight hours to the experience
it's a long time
which is part of the reason we need new
physical spaces to actually do the care
and why we're opening up field trip
health centers
um but you know that's a big commitment
that's a full day
you know and that's a lot of therapist
time that's a lot of doctor time it
makes it incredibly expensive if you
talk to people within the psychedelic
industry in the community one of the big
challenges is access
because it's so expensive not so
expensive but it is expensive to go for
a professionally
delivered psychedelic experience because
it takes a lot of
professional time and space to actually
go through the experience so
you know when we were looking at the
opportunities in this emerging industry
we realize that that
time frame makes it challenging to make
this scalable you know can you shrink
the time frame but not
diminish or not significantly diminish
the experience and the therapeutic
outcomes
and if you can find that right balance
with shorter time frames but similar
efficacy you know you've got a really
successful product and so uh so ft-104
was derived from known psychedelic
compounds
that engage the same receptor the
5-hd2-a receptor in the brain
but was specifically designed so it's an
experience in about two hours you know
you have
peak experience and um
most of it processed and out of your
bloodstream within about two hours
as opposed to four six eight or whatever
for psilocybin
and what that does is and it has the
same potency in the brain and engages
that five hd2 receptor with the same
binding capacity roughly as
as psilocybin so you have an experience
that's going to be as intense as potent
but can be done in a morning instead of
an entire day so it makes it more
accessible for people who can do this in
half a day potentially
as a therapeutic option and you don't
need as much time
and that's why we focused on ft-104 but
chemically
you know um we know it engages the right
receptors there are a lot of known
tryptamines
out there um and uh and so
um that engage that receptor and so you
know it's been derived
along that basis from that knowledge
that tryptomines engage
um the 5-ht2 receptor and so we're quite
excited about it we're still in
pre-clinical stages but
we have a good basis to know that it is
safe and efficacious and so we expect to
be able to move through the
approval process relatively expediently
what does that approval process look
like
it's a long one and it's an expensive
one so um the
the fda clinical trials typically are
three phases phase one phase two phase
three
phase one is really uh establishing that
it's safe to administer in humans
um phase two is really starting to do
dose finding
um to figure out how much you're going
to be
administering to people for the
therapeutic effect and then phase three
is
a much broader uh study with more people
showing that it actually works in the
intended way
um with with the given doses and then
there's often phase four
and beyond and you know it typically
takes compass pathways is right now
um in phase 2b and they've been at it
for four or five years
uh maps has been at this for close to 30
years and they're in phase three but
that's
that's really the exception not the norm
given that they were the ones were
really building the evidence to get the
fda comfortable with the idea of doing
psychedelics
um but yeah so if you know compass
pathways expects approval sometime
around 2025 2026 i think based on their
disclosure so
they're in it for 10 years and hundreds
of billions of dollars
um because it's expensive and it takes a
long time and you know the fda
approval process is rigorous as it
should be um
you know this is medicine and and we
need to show efficacy and safety but
it's also one of the reasons
that we've been big supporters of
measure 109 which is
you know a psychedelics from a drug
development and an investment
perspective psychedelics are
good investments if you think about it
because we know most psychedelics have
been used anecdotally for many many
years
we know them to be relatively safe we
know them to be relatively effective so
you've kind of de-risked
two of the biggest risk drug development
of does it work and is it safe
well we kind of know that already so to
some extent we're doing these clinical
trials knowing the outcome by and large
because of
all the history that's been out there
absolutely
one of the things that's really
interesting to me is uh
you described having centers in the
united states
these health centers and we obviously
just saw oregon
uh kind of decriminalize a lot of
uh what most people consider hard drugs
or illicit drugs
uh but also legalize the use of
uh silocibin uh maybe talk a little bit
about the difference there between
decriminalizing this stuff
versus legalizing the use case um and
kind of how you guys
viewed those two pathways and like is
one better than the other
or you agnostic to that we're not
agnostic to it we definitely support
legalization and regulation uh as
opposed to decriminalization
decriminalization don't get me wrong
it's still a step
in the right direction you know for most
drugs
uh that are not harmful uh like cannabis
and lsd and psilocybin by and large i
mean
we talked about the harm profile just
being low they're not harmless but
um you know it just doesn't make sense
to put people in prison
uh philosophically morally economically
it just is it seems to have been a bad
decision to conduct this war on drugs so
we support decriminalization
but decriminalization creates new risks
right because most people don't
distinguish between
legalization and decriminalization they
think oh it's been decriminalized it's
now legal
that's not true it just means that
enforcement and that particular
jurisdiction around possession has been
brought down to the lowest levels and
may be a fine or not enforced at all but
doesn't make it legal
um more importantly though it means that
you probably have a lot of people
thinking it's legal going out and
accessing it
buying supply from who knows what you
know you can't confirm the
the purity or anything along those lines
so it creates a whole bunch of risks and
you know i think rick doblin said it
best that the most important thing we
can do as part of the psychedelic
industry right now is not [ __ ] it up
right
and so when people go out and start
self-dosing and self-administering
buying supply from who knows where you
have the risk of
bad outcomes you have the risk of bad
trips or bad behavior and that can
really set it back
so you know decriminalization is good
because you don't want to be putting
people in prison for it it's expensive
and it makes
typically people worse not better when
they when they leave after a prison
experience
but legalization making sure that
there's safe access
controlled supply tested supplies so
people know what they're taking they
know the purity they know the dosage
they know they have the right
therapeutic support around it
just makes a lot more sense to us you
know at least at these early stages to
show that
we can integrate psychedelics back into
our society in a thoughtful way without
creating many unintended consequences
maybe once we've done that it makes
sense to enable broader access i i don't
know
we'll see but doing a legalized
regulated framework exactly like
proposed and
or now approved in oregon is smart
it ensures access it ensures that people
who want it can get
it but the people who are administering
it still have to ask the right questions
because you know if you
if you do have schizophrenia taking a
psychedelic is probably not a wise idea
and so you have people responsible for
asking the right questions and really
being a bit of a gaining
step to make sure that uh people who
shouldn't be accessing it aren't
and that you know they're responsible
for making sure people have good and
safe experiences as well and
i think that's definitely the right
approach absolutely if
somebody is in the united states you
know california
uh new york texas just pick a state
uh and they say look i want to
start down the path of the experience
with psychedelics
what's legally available to them today
right so organ
is kind of an outlier but can somebody
walk into a field trip health center
and take ketamine mdma
you know something else uh is it
something where they need a
um a doctor's subscription like just how
how does that work in terms of what's
legally available
yeah right now the only legally
prescribable
psychedelic outside of clinical trials
you know generally available
is ketamine it was approved by the fda
actually in the 1970s it's been around
for a long time it's known to be very
safe
by and large if your kid breaks a bone
and you take them to the emergency room
if the doctor is going to
prescribe something to help manage the
pain especially if they have to reset
the bone or something
along those lines it's ketamine that's
often prescribed so it is that kind of
safe and known commodity
um so ketamine is the only thing that's
currently prescribable mdma and
psilocybin are still scheduled
uh in the u.s and so they're not
accessible at least legally speaking
if you come into a field trip health
center
it does depend on the jurisdiction so in
some states
it's more restrictive and we could only
prescribe and administer to people who
have
say treatment resistant depression
in other states you know the bar may be
lower there's still be some sort of
medical need uh that has to exist right
now so it could be as simple as
dysthymia or adjustment disorder which
basically means i'm stuck in a rut
something that most people probably
ordinarily would go see a therapist for
or something along those lines you know
in some states we can prescribe and
administer for that in other states we
can't but there's always got to be some
sort of medical need right now
if you just want to come in to go for a
trip
typically that's not enabled or
permitted in most states
um but you know by and large people who
are coming in
typically have a need you can usually
establish some degree of medical need in
our centers
and what will happen is depending on the
need whether you have treatment
resistant depression or something sort
of less significant or impactful
there'll be a treatment program
developed so the typical treatment
program for someone with depression
is six ketamine sessions with six
exploratory
therapy sessions so back to back uh over
the course of a few weeks
uh with three integration sessions
interspersed kind of thing and that's
what it typically looked like but if
you're coming in for
dysthymia or adjustment disorder or just
having a hard time with life these days
you know it'd probably just be two
ketamine sessions with exploratory
therapy and integration work afterwards
got it it you guys are obviously not the
only player in the space
um it seems like everyone that i've come
across
is taking very different approaches
right and some of that's because they're
actually solving for
different things some of them are more
kind of the compound and drug focused
uh some of them are more the physical
space and kind of the setting
you guys are taking kind of this hybrid
approach um talk a little bit about just
how
you see who the other large players are
in the space
and kind of your view on what they're
doing sure
so obviously there's field trip health
which we're on the canadian securities
exchange and publicly listed right now
the biggest player in the industry is
compass pathways they recently went
public on the nasdaq
they are in phase 2b of fda
approved clinical trials for psilocybin
for the treatment
of treatment resistant depression they
are taking a very
um pharmaceutical biotech approach
uh to psychedelics just focus on the
drug they're not focused on the satin
setting
or anything along those lines they
really want to just be
a pharmaceutical company within this
context at least that's the path they're
taking
and i've spoken at length with some of
the founders and they're all
you know really great people really
thoughtful people and see
the broader context of the psychedelic
industry but they're focused on taking
the specific path right now because i
think it's the most
expeditious and appropriate way
um they they are the biggest player the
biggest investor
in compass pathways is a company called
atai life sciences
they're essentially a holding company or
a vc depending on how you want to look
at it they own or have invested in a
number of different
pharmaceutical companies early stage
pharmaceutical companies that are
developing
different psychedelics or mental health
treatments it's not always psychedelics
within entire life sciences but
mental health more broadly um you know
very credible players as well not
surprising they were instrumental to the
creation of compass pathways and so they
have very similar
outlooks and operations those are the
two
biggest players there is a company
called mind medicine
which is on the neo exchange in canada
they just announced an intention to list
on the nasdaq
they started off with an interesting
approach they were moving forward with
clinical trials with a molecule called
18mc which is similar to lsd
but it doesn't cause the trip and that
creates actually some philosophical
discussions within the community of
do you need the trip do you need that
psychedelic experience to actually have
the therapeutic outcomes or can it be
achieved just on a neural chemical basis
and the 18mc
they're advancing for the treatment of
opioid addiction
and it doesn't have the trip it's really
a classic
pharmaceutical product in that respect
but they're also doing work with lsd and
micro dosing and
attention deficit disorder in adults
so they are progressing as well there's
a number of other smaller companies
out there most
focused on doing drug development so
pursuing the clinical path
and just that side of the equation i
think that's what makes field trip
really unique is the integrated approach
that we're taking
because we think both elements are so
critically important to the therapeutic
outcomes that you can't leave the other
one just a chance
and so that's what we've taken the path
that we've taken and how do you guys
see this developing right so if we kind
of zoom out
from an industry standpoint is this
something where
what just happened in oregon is kind of
a broaching of
what will happen on every single state
level in the united states you'll
eventually get fda approvals
this will look like the cannabis
industry but just be on a larger scale
the same size scale
like how does this kind of play out in
terms of
what people can expect moving forward
from an industry level
yeah and i should know i mean we've
drawn the parallels between cannabis and
psychedelics quite a bit and there are
some parallels certainly i mean
obviously there's stigmatized medicine
and they're similar
in that um you need a new infrastructure
to really deliver this the existing
medical infrastructure is not well
suited to it
what does distinguish psychedelics from
cannabis is cannabis by and large is an
industry
for itself you know there's people who
use cannabis there's people who will
start to use cannabis but you know it
it's not displacing anything except
maybe some some alcohol
consumption psychedelics on the other
hand are a much larger potential from an
industry perspective because when you
look at the evidence when you see that
mdma can effectively cure ptsd when you
can see that
psilocybin can effectively cure
depression for
months or years at a time um psilocybin
therapy and mdma therapy
you know what you're talking about is a
fundamental displacement of
most approaches to mental health it's a
much bigger opportunity than just
cannabis in terms of
business potential um what i see
happening over the next few years is is
pretty much
the path that we're already on you know
oregon was the only state to approve
um access to psilocybin therapies this
year but
california had efforts underway that
were really derailed by the
the pandemic you can expect california
to be added again you can expect
colorado to have a ballot initiative in
two years
new york state potentially there are
going to be a number of states that look
to roll out these programs and in a
wellness kind of approach very similar
to oregon we really
think oregon has set the foundation for
what this is going to look like and i
think that continues and i think that
continues in parallel with the fda
process
because i think you're going to see both
the medical need
with synthetic products and insurance
coverage and you're going to see
the more wellness need for natural
products and broader access for people
who don't necessarily have clinical
diagnoses with mental health conditions
but see the benefit of accessing
psychedelic therapies
you know and more broadly and
philosophically and what excites me
about
the psychedelic renaissance that's
happening right now is that i think it
really
changes the conversation around mental
and emotional health you know for me
the psychedelic drugs are not the
important aspect of it
uh the important aspect of it is that i
think the conversation around
psychedelics is going to
make mental and emotional health
proactive we're going to start thinking
about
our mental health like we think about
our physical fitness we all know we
should go to the gym no one's going to
argue that going to the gym is
good for you we don't always do it but
we know that
you know could you imagine going to the
gym only once you've broken your ankle
or pulled a muscle like that's not it
doesn't make sense and and i think we
need to start thinking about our mental
and emotional health that way and i
think psychedelics are going to be the
platform where people are going to be
much more proactive
about ensuring their mental health is is
well established and they're constantly
working on it just like we're constantly
working on our physical fitness and
that's really what excites me
um and so i think psychedelics are
really just the catalyst for a
much broader conversation around all of
this kind of stuff and so there's going
to be
incredible opportunities within
psychedelics and psychedelic drug
development
and cultivation of psilocybin and peyote
and all the natural products as well
uh and i think they'll operate very
nicely in tandem and parallel much like
you see
adult use cannabis and medical cannabis
operating in parallel they're
they're set up you know so that there's
broad access but people have different
paths to get there
absolutely it's fascinating to me
as i kind of went down this uh this
rabbit hole if you will and you were
kind enough to send me a bunch of uh
information to uh to kind of read up on
where would you suggest
other people who are listening to this
and uh interested
and want to learn more where can they go
or is there a book
is there um specific resources that you
say like this is the best place to kind
of get
started on on the educational side yeah
i always give the nod and you won't be
surprised by this to michael paul and
michael pollan's how to change your mind
it is a very thoughtful great read about
the history of psychedelics the the
modern movement
you know it gives you a good flavor of
what the experiences are like it's it's
a really good
overview of everything that's going on
um
i'm also a big fan of the harvard
psychedelic club if you like history if
you like knowing the narrative of the
experience which was written by don
latin
it talks about the experience with
timothy leary and richard albert who
became ram das and a lot of the
seminal figures that are still present
today
um at least in the story even though
timothy leary is dead
because you know we have to learn from
our past experiences and the
mistakes that were made along the way to
make sure that we don't create similar
circumstances
those are two great great resources
maps you know has a newsletter uh and
tons of information as well that's a
that's a great resource
those are the typically the places i
point people but
you know it's growing so quickly um
uh that uh you know there's things
popping up if people are interested from
an investment perspective
uh there's resources like psychedelic
finance or psilocybin alpha that are
tracking the
the publicly listed companies right now
they're they're great resources as well
um i can't think of anything off the top
of my head beyond that but i'm sure
other things will come up
you said that you guys have a podcast
what do you talk about on there
yeah so it's called field tripping epic
trips and psychedelics
and really my goal is to mainstream the
conversation so have people talk about
their psychedelic experiences
what it meant to them and how it changed
the course of their life so
we've had people like dr andrew weil on
we've had director x we had
alex icon we've had really incredible
people come on and talk about how
psychedelics has
has really altered the course of their
lives in a positive way
and talking about their experiences and
um
and we also had humble the poet whose
episode you know i've had
many people reach out to me talk about
how it brought them to tears because it
was
so emotional and it's resonated with
them so much because one of the things
going back to my comment about
psychedelics being the platform that
really changes the conversation about a
mental and emotional health
one of the most important things is that
we actually start talking about our
emotions and
our mental health and and so it's a
platform for people to talk about that
and we kind of go into their experiences
and
what you know it showed for them and
having done a lot of work
myself on exploration and metaphysics
you know i try where i can to offer
insights saying like oh had you ever
considered that this
may be something that that psychedelic
experience was showing you
uh and uh so that yeah that's that's the
podcast
if you're interested in um field trip
health centers you know the the website
is fieldtrip health.com
if you're interested from an investment
perspective we have a website or
corporate website which is meet
fieldtrip.com
um and then if you're interested in our
ab trip you can always go to trip
app.co which is where you can download
that and that was really designed for
anybody doing consciousness expansion
work
helping them set intentions providing
them with a really
impactful soundscapes and music to
support the experience and then doing
the integration work afterwards which is
what something we haven't talked about
much but
that's where most people will say the
real magic and psychedelics happen
it's like you have the psychedelic
experience but what you take from that
experience and how you
integrate that into your lives is where
the real sustained
meaningful change happens and so a trip
gives you
a fairly simplified way to start
doing that integration work reflect on
the experience and trying to understand
what it means so you can actually change
you know your habits your behavior
outlook all of these kind of things as
well
i love it before we wrap up i asked
everyone the same two questions
and then you'll get a chance to ask me
one question uh the first question
is what is the most important book
you've ever read i feel like you may
have already answered that but any other
books that you want to
uh to add in there yeah michael pollan's
book is great but it's not the most
important book i've ever read
i think the two most impactful books
i've read um
actually i'm going to say three because
i always flip back and forth tom robbins
is my favorite author if you listen to
the podcast you'll hear me quote him
all the time and it's not tony robbins
it's tom robbins people get that
confused and it's not tim robbins either
it's uh tom robbins um he wrote most
people have heard of even cowgirls got
the blues but that's not the book i'm
going to reference
jitterbug perfume or still life with
woodpecker
um are just fascinating they're
you know his his prose is the most
eloquent i've ever read
uh and his philosophy and his creativity
are just mind-blowing and they inspire
me every time i remember reading still
life with woodpecker one night
sitting up in bed after reading a
particular passage and just being like
that is the most insightful thoughtful
inspiring thing i've ever read and it
actually inspired me to do something
stupid
in a good way but uh that's how
impactful it was um so
cheater bug perfume and still life with
woodpecker and then
also there's a book it's probably 20
years old now called the rebel cell
why the counterculture can't be jammed
it just takes like a really
honest approach about capitalism its
benefits and its limitations and and it
was written as a response to
naomi klein's no logo um i think
uh which was a really i think impactful
book
back in the day uh in the
anti-capitalist movement and it was just
a response to that and it's
so thoughtful and and i think well
grounded
that i always go back to it and just
remind myself about how to think about
things from a
more logical and intuitive perspective
as opposed to a black and white
perspective those are those are the two
books that i would recommend
those are great suggestions uh the
second question is more fun
uh aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
uh i'm a believer that there is life in
this universe you can't look at the size
and scale and
everything that's going on in fact i
took a course in university called life
in other worlds and i thought the
professor did a good job of answering
that question he said
is there life on other worlds and a word
yes in two words
yes probably and then he kind of strung
it out and it's like it's true
you know it's hard to believe that
there's all that space all that
potential
and and we're the only planet with with
life on it so
so yes i'm a believer whether they've
come to visit us or not
i'm a little bit more skeptical uh um
i'm right there with you on all of that
and i wish i had a class in college that
would have uh would have
put me down that rabbit hole that's
pretty cool uh you could ask me one
question to
wrap this up what do you got for me all
right i mean it's gonna be straight up
have you ever tried psychedelics
if so what was the experience and if not
why not
yeah so no uh and more so just a lack of
uh access and education probably right
like a thing of just
um the
whole idea of like if i want to get
drunk right now
like i know exactly where to go right
like go right to the liquor store go
right to
buy some beer right and it's a pretty
easy exercise of uh
open up whatever the bottle or can is
and and drink
yeah and uh so i think that that's
probably been like the biggest barrier
uh and the second thing also is like i
don't wanna say it's misinformation but
definitely this idea
or maybe like the stigmatization of like
oh
that's like for this group of people
that's kind of like on the fringes of
society
um and with most things which you
realize is like
one no that's not true two uh everything
seems
scary or different uh if you don't know
anything about it right you know i
deal with that like on the bitcoin side
all the time you're like oh that that's
for drug dealers and you know terrorists
then you learn about you're like oh
maybe not right so yeah i think that
that's probably
the and i'm assuming for most people
listening like that's the two biggest
barriers right it's like
what is this stuff how does it work why
is it important
um you know what am i putting my body
all that kind of stuff and then two is
just an access thing right and i think
what you guys are doing from like the
health center standpoint
um just drastically reduces that barrier
uh and you could easily see that being
an inflection point from an adoption
uh perspective totally makes sense and
and part like that's
that's the reason for the podcast is
when you hear of all of these incredibly
successful people and also a nod to
donek kerry who
has a documentary on on netflix called
um have a good trip
uh where he talks to like incredibly
famous people about their psychedelic
experiences
really just trying to mainstream and so
it's not people don't think about it as
like oh it's the people
out there on the fringes it's you know
very successful
very impactful very normal people who
who have these experiences
and then yeah on the access side
certainly what's you know
canada is a bit of a liberal haven and
it's kind of nice especially given my
philosophical and political meanings but
back in 2018
beyond the fact that uh we learned about
uh michael pollan's book and we you know
maps had been given breakthrough
designation and really what inspired us
the other piece was that
we got alerted to the fact that in
canada there's now probably 50
uh online stores openly selling
psilocybin producing mushrooms
and interestingly as far as i know only
one has been shut down
and it wasn't shut down by you know the
the police raiding it it was shut down
because health canada sent the polite
letter saying you're selling an
unauthorized medicine for treatment of
you know conditions that's not
authorized you know that and that's what
it was and so
you know in canada even though it's
still very much illicit and
illegal uh accessing supply has become
much easier
and it's not dark web you know this is
www kind of
stuff and uh and uh and so yeah you know
that kind of access i think has helped
mainstream it quite a bit in urban
centers as well
canadians are so much nicer than
americans americans would have sent the
swat team with machine guns
and you know you would have thought a
murder was happening and canadians send
the letters
that's exactly right that does not
surprise me one one uh
one bit at all uh listen ronan i really
appreciate you doing this this is uh
fantastic i've learned a ton uh both in
preparation for this and then obviously
in this conversation
um you mentioned a couple of websites
where people can go find out more about
a field trip where can they find you on
the internet if they've got questions or
can i want to talk to you more about
some of this stuff
yeah twitter uh it's ronan d as in david
levy levy is my twitter handle um
instagram's the same thing i'm on
linkedin uh facebook i don't use very
much anymore so
probably twitter and linkedin are the
best places to find me
uh field trip if you want to follow us
it's at fieldtrip health on twitter and
instagram as well and the websites again
are meetfieldtrip.com for our corporate
and ir
site fieldtrip health.com which is for
our field trip health centers
and tripapp.co if you're interested in
the app trip awesome man well listen
thank you so much for doing this
uh we absolutely are going to have to do
this again
and uh hopefully after i uh make my way
to canada or somewhere else and then we
can uh we can talk a little bit more in
depth
yeah absolutely i was going to say that
the pitch for like all the online stores
would only have enhanced
things for a lot of people had donald
trump on the election but
i think a lot of people are a little bit
stated these days with
at least it looking like joe biden will
be the next president so
that that's good news at least for the
population of the us
uh who who were terrified by the
alternative outcome
absolutely all right sir thank you so
much we'll do it again in the future
my pleasure thanks for having me